um when it comes to
the backlog um you know
as you know it's it's it's challenging
to get numbers
one because we we track by issues not
human beings um and the second is you
know we continue to get ten
tens of thousands of claims every week
uh
so um it's difficult to keep track i
i i feel pretty confident uh barbara
might
uh clarify this answer but
um we were really focused on getting
through
the the pua folks who had been waiting
for
a resolution so i think we we've caught
up to
sort of everybody who had applied uh
by the time the task force was created
the strike force
um and now we're um we're really focused
by
issue on getting through folks that
have come in since then so you know
dealing with identity we're
we're sending about 50 000 idme requests
to
new applications we've had uh that we
need that verification
uh and we also had a quarter change
which means
we again have to look at did you have ui
eligibility
so the welfare folks i think are
spending this weekend next
on getting through that um so in pua at
least we're getting very close to having
a resolution for
most of the folks who have come in uh
and we're still
looking at in ui
we need to implement the special session
yeah uh regulations to resolve about 20
000 of those claims
uh we're still working on the
programming for that uh
and then just have people processing
those claims
barbara did you have something to add to
them
no i i think that's about right um we
continue to add staff
between the staffing and the automation
uh again we're we're hoping to see
large amounts of clearances in the next
two weeks
perfect and then phone lines any are any
of these workers going to be jumping on
the phone lines what's up
what's up with that
yeah we um you know we we certainly
hoped we would be able to answer a
lot higher percentage of calls by now um
and it's still not where it should be
for sure
we had some issues that came up this
week that sort of
increased the call volume when it had
been going down so that
you know that made it a little tougher
this week and next we're adding about 50
staff
from our contract staffing and it's just
you know we have to get them set up so
they have access to both systems
which takes a little bit of time through
our it department
um but we expect them to start making a
difference and and as usual we get
new folks and it takes them a week or
two to kind of get up to speed but we
are adding 50 new folks
and we're looking at uh redeploying a
a large chunk of the welfare folks maybe
up to 50 of them
in the next week or two so um
we're we are committed to making it work
and it's just you know getting all the
pieces in place and getting
folks sort of up to speed yeah so uh
yesterday
rosa did update me week five of lost
wages will be happening um
when and is there any status on week six
i know it goes by a weekly basis on how
much money goes out
right we're actually still uh we we have
a few more
payments for week four to go this week
um so next week we will start
week five and as we've said before
pua gets to go out like in one day so
that will go out by thanksgiving and it
takes us about 10 days to roll out
all of the regular ui folks um
so they'll have that in the next two
weeks we have requested
an amendment to our grant from fema
to accommodate all the new people that
have filed
that would be eligible and we have not
yet heard back
so we're still looking at it we've
we've we've done what we can
and now we have to hear back from fema
perfect um
i know this week there's a lot going on
overpayment notices
were dropped for a lot of people um you
guys had sent me a couple of
reasons why can you briefly just just
describe
why these why so many went out this week
yeah i think it goes back to what mike
was saying
is that when the pandemic first hit we
really
were sort of focused on getting benefits
out to folks so a lot of
people got pua benefits and then
as we look deeper into their claims it
turned out
they had ui wages that they
should have applied for and exhausted
their benefits in the ui system that's
the federal law we don't have any
flexibility around that so if you got
those pua payments
and then we later were able to move you
over to ui to get
benefits there those pua payments would
be overpayments
um so those that's a big chunk of folks
that are getting these notices
uh and the other the other largest group
is
is folks where wear what they filled out
in their application in terms of
income and what their documentation
shows
their self-employment income to be uh
don't match
and so they maybe got benefits that were
higher than what the documentation
would uh warrant so they would have been
getting higher weekly benefits than
than than we can allow based on the
documentation so they would have a
little bit of an overpayment as well
those are the two biggest buckets we
think
um so the the important thing for folks
to know
is um you know they there's instructions
in that overpayment notice about how to
appeal
these decisions and any determination
that
dater has made can be appealed so the
if you disagree with the weekly benefit
amount if you agree with the
fact that there is an overpayment if you
disagree with the overpayment amount
you can appeal that and it's very
important for claimants to follow the
instructions
and file those appeals uh within the
time frame
that's outlined and
if if they uh you know agree that there
is an overpayment they can contact
our benefit protection payment control
office and set up a payment plan so
that's the other thing they can do
do you have a timeline on how long
appeals are estimated to be taking for
an individual because i
talked to a couple who have two appeals
they're in review and they've been in
review for a while
yeah we um this is where
we're we're still working on the
automation
piece um you know to to do an appeal
it's sort of a
semi-legal process so we have to pull
all the documentation together and uh
we we just got that module online in pua
and we're still working out some of the
details so
we have had a few hundred scheduled
and we we know we have about seven or
eight hundred that
are sort of ready to go and be scheduled
but
we're just working through that first
couple hundred to
sort of get the process uh all the
pieces in place
and then once once we get it set up so
that it's working smoothly we should
be able to get through them pretty
quickly but we're just not quite there
yet
okay joe joe i wanted to mention one
other thing
on the overpayments it's important to
note that some
some folks may get a overpayment notice
on their pua benefits
and then they get an overpayment notice
on the federal
six hundred dollar bump the
extra at this six hundred dollar bump um
that overpayment can be waived
the pua overpayments themselves cannot
be waived under federal law
yesterday i sent a request to the
congressional delegation
asking them that if they're looking at
reauthorization of pua
allow states to waive the overpayments
retroactively back to the beginning of
the program
because some people made honest mistakes
right
we asked for their net wages let's say
they were an uber driver
uber gives them a statement saying what
their net wages are
right so they include that but it's not
the net from their occupation
that they report to the irs so they may
have made a mistake
if in regular unemployment states can
wave over payments when it's due to no
fault of their own it was
it would be against equity and good
conscience to require the overpayment
that's the kind of language we want to
see in pua
as well so we're hoping to get some
positive
news from our congressional delegation
on that point
okay good thanks for throwing that in
there i appreciate that um
obviously cases are going up are you
guys a
concerned about another shutdown and is
there anything you guys are doing to
prepare for a possible another shutdown
because i could mean
another whole wave of uh unemployment
claimants
yeah um the governor isn't uh talking
about that we're just talking about
sort of increasing the caution um
that people are taking and the the
precautions people are taking i know
we are at dieter uh re looking again at
are there more folks we can
have work from home are there more ways
to space people out and keep our
employees safe
and so i i think that we are
you know our goal has always been to
process and resolve as many cases
as possible uh my concern
for folks is um they really need to
everybody really needs to be looking
ahead at you know what
what can we be doing to sort of protect
ourselves
and do everything we can to
get our economic situation under control
several of these benefit programs like
pua
and the pandemic emergency uh
unemployment compensation which adds
extra weeks to ui those expire at the
end of the year
unless congress acts uh i don't
know when i i do believe congress will
act but we don't know when
so people need to be prepared there may
be a disruption and benefits
uh people need to be thinking about that
and that there's not anything the state
can do about that that is a federal
situation
and so the other thing we're really
encouraging people to do is think about
you know is it time to get new skills
training
uh new news news certificates
new go back to school because some of
these jobs
it's going to be a long time before they
come back so uh we're
we're very concerned overall uh i think
the
the state is doing everything i can to
help get people back to work but
um some of this is in congress's hands
yeah
are you worried about another wave of i
mean
claimants i mean if they do if there is
a possible shutdown people are put out i
mean are you guys
is there anything you can do to prepare
for that because i know it'd just be a
massive more backlog i think
yeah it's um you know it's it's
definitely
a worry um joe um
we know people will be desperate for for
benefits
uh the one good thing that we've done to
prepare
is some of the issues like deductible
income let's say
an employer is able to give a weak
severance
thanks to sb3 the legislature and the
governor that won't hold up benefits
like it did before
so that's one proactive thing we've done
another thing that's not ready yet but
we recommended
in in the state of georgia they have the
employers
start all the unemployment benefits
because employees right it may be the
first time they've ever had to file for
unemployment
and the system is foreign well if you
have trained hr people that can assist
it can make the reduce the backlogs and
make the system go
smoother we're not ready to launch that
yet but it's one of the recommendations
from the strikeforce to do in the future
um now quickly here before we run out of
time i know that the recent update we
got this week showed a 40
decrease in new initial pool claims but
there was a increase in extended
benefits and something was still being
looked into
can you guys elaborate on that at all
yeah um there's a lot of moving parts
in unemployment so uh in regular
unemployment
it lasts for 26 weeks so we're we're now
seeing a lot of folks run out of that
they move
over to the pandemic emergency
unemployment compensation
which is something congress put in place
uh that's
13 weeks 20 weeks 13 weeks i think
and then that expires
also at the end of the year unless
congress acts and then
under certain circumstances then those
folks can move on to
state extended benefits so that's part
of what you're seeing is people moving
from
one program to another as they exhaust
uh
different benefit programs um pua
the the pua numbers have fluctuated
pretty wildly from
week to week we had a pretty um we did
have for
the two previous weeks we had a pretty
big spike
and we we i don't have any
good idea about why we're still sort of
looking at those claims
uh and that's why you see it come down
something like 40
is it's now back down to sort of normal
numbers that we would expect uh so
whenever i try and do a story there's
also people who reach out to me like
what about
us who have applied in the spring and we
still haven't gotten anything
any word for those folks out there
yeah joe one of the things that we're
doing um with
the with our new administrator for
unemployment um who was uh appointed a
couple weeks ago
we've asked for a list of any claim
from from the beginning that is not
processed to see if any have fallen
through
between the cracks while we have sent a
large
amount of claims to be verified through
id me
so that we can catch those because
we want every claim assigned right
and we feel like we have every claim
assigned but we don't want to miss
anyone
and i think the people who reach out to
you and reach out to us
they're the ones that are falling
between the cracks and we've got to get
every one of those resolved
is there any time frame you can put on
that
yeah i mean it's our hope for the pua
system
to do all of these in the next two weeks
i mean we feel like we're at the bottom
of of uh resolution for pua
and then we want to put the extra
resources the labor
on the ui claims and then do the
automation changes from sb3 to clear out
another 20
000 from ui that's the plan
people are desperate they we need to get
to their claims
yeah no we hear the stories all the time
and it definitely is
something that um obviously people are
getting desperate because they need the
money i'm hearing a lot of stories about
people
um what is the best way for someone to
reach out
to dieter right now if they're trying to
get questions answered
i know a lot of people are having issues
with the maiden name sort of thing i
know a lot of people are having issues
just trying to get through
on a phone line or um they might have an
issue with their portal what's the best
way for someone to get through and your
guys's opinion
um i would i would say a couple of
things i think a lot of the folks i've
seen
calling or emailing or texting me
is they've got a decision that they
don't
like they've they've been found
ineligible and they
disagree um and if if you
have had a decision that dieter made
that you disagree with
the best possible thing to do is
uh to to follow the instructions on that
notification and file an appeal
um because there's a timeline for filing
an appeal
and i know it's it's very frustrating
because for some people they just want a
an explanation and they just want to
talk to someone and have them walk them
through their claim
um but uh their those
those appeal rights are sort of limited
by time
so that's that's an important thing for
people to do is file an appeal
if they don't like the decision um we do
we have been updating our
sort of frequently asked questions on
the website they're
they they still could be made a little
more easy to follow but we're we're
working on updating those so that's a
place they might get an answer
uh and we are adding folks to the phones
so the the the things i keep saying
about the phones are
monday and tuesday are the heaviest days
so don't call then
the first thing in the morning is not
good that's
that's pretty hectic and by three or
four most days the
the queue where people can hold is shut
off
so the best time to call is in the
middle of the day
wednesday thursday friday that's those
are my
tips i don't know if barbara has any
others
no i think i i think that sums it up
perfect
um so back to appeals real quick i
i keep thinking of these different
scenarios that i've talked to someone
was told that they owe a certain amount
like
those around 14 000 by uh november 11th
they want to appeal are they is there
any sort of repercussion for
someone like that if they're not paying
that by the 30th but they're waiting for
their appeal to be reviewed
no people have the right to have an
appeal and
um there's no repercussions um
that a an appeals referee will then
determine whether or not they owe it
and you know i i think the other thing
about these overpayments joe
is that people shouldn't get too
stressed out about them
i know it's stressful to get a notice
but look if they're out of work
they're out of work right the
the important thing is if they think
it's legally wrong
to file their appeal to have an
independent referee look at it
right and at that point later on
um they can look at a repayment plan
they can look to when they get a job
but you know it's people are under a lot
of stress right now
and i think what they need to do is
appeal it if they think it's wrong
don't get too stressed out about it the
state's going to work with them
okay um sorry another example
someone who had claimed their money they
were told to do pua but then eventually
later told to be in ui and they got
switched over
but then all the the disqualifications
and pua
are still there and then they got it
just an overpayment for pua to pay money
back
that's where the situation's a little
tricky because they're still getting
paid in ui but they
technically had something in cool is
that because that account was open in
pool and that that's why that was sent
yeah people can't receive double
payments from both systems
well he wasn't getting payments from
from pua it was just ui because he was
disqualified
in pua yeah then then he shouldn't
owe an overpayment i mean if he didn't
get the money
he wouldn't uh he wouldn't have to pay
anything back and if the system
again you know dieter is a little
dependent on its vendors who create
these systems
if the system generated an overpayment
notice and someone to
get the money they should appeal that
because it's wrong and it will be
corrected
okay good to know um i think any of the
questions i had i think um i know we're
any other time here but
um you guys basically answered all of
those
anything any suggestions for anybody
else out there if they're
looking to file here in the near future
i know we're on the brink of
california just had a little shutdown
like that
any suggestions for people
um if they're newly laid off
um i think it's important to kind of you
know not
panic and um maybe look at the website
first learn a little bit about the
system
so that they you know don't answer
questions wrong
um you know there are some guidance on
the website like for example
if uh sometimes people will the question
might be are you looking for work
right and um people will panic and
they'll answer it wrong and then it will
hang up their claim so you know
feel free to just you know take a moment
you know look at the website look at
some of the instructions
first because it's easier for them and
the system
if they don't make a mistake when
they're filling out the forms and i
think that's a worry because a lot of
people obviously know someone on
unemployment and they've heard some of
the issues they've had and they're
nervous
trying to do it themselves because they
don't want to mess something up and then
end up with
an overpayment notification or something
like that yeah and and
and you know i think maybe that's
something we can look at too if we can
give you know the top five things people
do wrong
you know like one thing we see on
unemployment for example is people will
say
well i was i was discharged right
um well they were laid off but then it's
confusing because under federal law you
get unemployment if you were laid off
but if you were discharged for
misconduct you don't
so it's kind of how they're
characterizing it so i mean i think
that's something that dieter can do
better
right maybe on its website look at the
frequently asked questions or the things
people do wrong
to make the system go a little smoother
and we've already
you know decided that that's something
we need to do so
check out the website uh last question
here i know
kobe obviously cases are going up you
guys are trying to take precautions is
there
is there anything delaying anything at
the department
offices in las vegas or even up north um
i know that you did have a case not too
long ago that kind of had things had to
be cleaned and everything like that
right we actually um we had a
we had a cleaning protocol uh and
of course we're following all the
governor's guidance on
best practices about working safely
we what happens is we we did have the
call center have to call
down or close down for a deep cleaning
uh
and then so the center call center in
the north picks up those calls
um so we we've got two things going one
is we've
uh we've put in place a more
aggressive cleaning protocol so we're
cleaning on a regular basis
to help reduce any cases of
covid and we are working to get the
technology in place
to be able to send some of our call
center staffers
to be able to work from home we just
don't have the phone
system yet uh this again is that
modernizing systems for the state
um you know we we may save money in the
short term by not making these
investments but
uh when something like this hits and
it's very difficult to respond
uh so so we are sort of upping our our
cleaning and safety protocols to
to keep folks safe and uh at work
perfect barbara added that are you good
no it's uh you know as as a volunteer
um i look at the challenges dieter has
right
it's computer systems it's vendors let
them down they think something's going
to be done a week ago
and then the vendor doesn't um complete
the project
or cove it happens right um you know we
we had hoped to get
um some computer changes done quicker
but the person
who was programming them came down with
covid
right so jeter has the same issues hr
issues that most businesses have right
and
um it's it's complicated
and uh it sets them back
even though they're trying their best on
some areas to get things done
but you know there's a lot of people
working really hard
so yeah and joe i would just add one
other thing for folks
who who are um who find themselves
unemployed and need to
file um you know what we don't talk
about
is there there are about 300 000
nevadans who
are getting continuing well for
our sorry that was my previous job
they're about 300 000 nevadans who are
getting continued
uh unemployment benefits on a weekly
basis
between ui the extended benefits and pua
so for a lot of nevadans this
this program is working and it is
providing
support in a lifeline which is helping
to keep
literally hundreds of thousands of
nevadans in their homes
and able to take care of their families
it isn't designed to be a continual
income source but it is designed to be a
bridge to get back to a place where they
can
be working again so um for a lot of
folks
even though we've we focus on the
problems for for many many nevadans this
this program is working and providing
critical support
perfect thank you for that uh all right
i will stop recording this